jobs literally the only reason that
anyone gets up before 11 a.m.
politicians care about jobs more than
anything else as you can tell from how
often they mention them these are the
things I focus on jobs jobs jobs jobs
jobs jobs jobs jobs and jobs jobs jobs
jobs it's about jobs jobs jobs
good-paying jobs it's about jobs jobs
jobs jobs and more jobs American jobs
politicians seem to think that jobs are
like beetlejuice if you just say the
words a magic number of times eventually
they'll just pop up out of nowhere now
more specifically tonight I'd like to
talk about one of the ways that
politicians try to create jobs economic
development incentives and I know that
that doesn't sound interesting wait wait
what are you doing you're putting the
picture-in-picture
it's that entourage the movie you know
what switch over the audio listen to the
first line you'll be back how about that
all of a sudden I show about economic
development doesn't seem like the worst
thing you could be watching doesn't so
as I was saying
economic development incentives are
essentially when state and local
governments offer perks to companies to
entice them to build or expand in their
area here in New York there is a program
called startup in New York which
launched with some pretty astounding tax
breaks startup New York creates zero tax
zone for new businesses for ten years
zero property checks zero corporate tax
zero business tax and zero income tax
zero property corporate business and
income tax and I believe that that sound
you just heard was Donald Trump getting
a nerection
wait for it don't worry wait for it's
glozell it's gone again see you next
year little buddy it's not just me look
all 50 states offers some kind of
incentives like tax breaks to attract
companies and the argument is that they
attract employers which attract jobs
which lead to spending which creates
more jobs and so on and so on and so on
and many places are bought into this
Hart trying to outbid one another for
businesses Indiana even once took out
attack ads on other states like this
billboard which read Illinois by higher
taxes come to Indiana a state that works
and that's pretty aggressive although
it's actually much tamer than their
original billboard just Arkansas your
tax bill I hope you like our tax breaks
because if you color are don't walk and
they're to cut your balls off
big enough it can even start a bidding
war itself that is actually happening
right now with Amazon they are planning
to build a second headquarters somewhere
in North America and they are making
government's bid for it they even
released eight pages of instructions for
candidates telling them to think big and
be creative which led many cities to do
stupid like this overnight the Big
Apple looking more like in Orange New
York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio lighting
up the city and quote Amazon orange the
city of Birmingham is using giant Amazon
boxes to try to get Amazon's attention
Stonecrest Georgia offering to create a
new town of Amazon Georgia
they would create a new town and name it
Amazon you know to compete on that
surprise that Omaha Nebraska didn't
offer to let Jeff Bezos kill any three
people he likes cuz you know he would
look at it he wants it so bad it's the
only thing he can't have and he wants it
and numerous mayor's made direct appeals
to Amazon with videos ending in versions
of the same bad joke hey Alexa where
should Amazon located HQ - hmm in Frisco
Texas Alexa where is the most
interesting company in the world
obviously Washington DC so Alexa where
is the best place for Amazon to locate
its second world headquarters Danbury
Connecticut I told you so
you know my one and only worry with all
of those ads and I mean this sincerely
is are they almost to hilarious but
those stunts are just window dressing
what Amazon cares much much more about
as they mentioned in their instructions
21 times are incentives and while few
places are revealing what they offered
we do know that New Jersey reportedly
offered seven billion dollars in tax
breaks which is an insane amount that
other places may now have to compete
with and think about what that means
that could mean billions of tax dollars
that would not be collected for things
like roads or schools or hospitals and
Amazon already has more money than it
knows what to do with how else can you
explain the existence of Goliath I show
that and this is true literally nobody
has ever seen
no body no human no animal no body no
but no one does it even exists
if you make it show and no one watches
it does it exist discuss and and that is
the thing here we give companies a lot
of money through these incentives by one
estimate in 2015 they cost state and
local governments forty five billion
dollars and that money can go to some
questionable projects for instance a few
years ago Kentucky took a big swing on
this a full-size replica of Noah's Ark
is drawing
thousands of visitors to Williamstown
Kentucky this is the Ark Encounter a
chapter from Genesis told on a hundred
million dollar budget four floors of
Noah his family and beasts great and
small the project received 18 million
dollars in Kentucky tax incentives 18
million dollars of tax breaks for a
gigantic Ark Museum and I'm not saying
that that is inherently a bad idea I do
kind of want to see this thing
especially as its website genuinely has
a section devoted to the question what
about all the man your the answer
apparently is slatted flaws on multiple
level cages which is really not a good
answer because you do not want to be the
animal on the lowest level of that ship
and while the ark clearly created some
jobs there were some caveats to those
positions critics complain of
discrimination in hiring only Christians
no gays or lesbians and single people
have to sign a chastity pledge Oh
aside from the homophobia chastity is a
pretty weird room to put in place but a
museum that's pretty much in gigantic
replica of a floating Zoo they
weren't brought in two by two so that
everyone would have a swim buddy
they were on that boat too far
but the justification for taking a
gamble on a gigantic art was there it
would be a boon to the whole area and to
hear one local official telling the
economic impact has been underwhelming
the Ark's success has not had the ripple
effect many hoped it would downtown
Williamstown which was expecting
increased car and foot traffic has
almost as many empty storefronts as
occupied storefronts what's it meant for
downtown Williamstown nothing negative
in this interview but there's nothing
here
yeah and that kind of makes sense
because once you've spent three hours
walking around a wooden boat with
sexually frustrated tour guides and
haunted by the mental image of a
miserable zebra neck deep in
because apparently decks were assigned
alphabetically yep you're probably gonna
skip lunch in town and look a
well-designed closely monitored program
with clear goals might make sense to an
area but too often the terms are
extremely lacks some don't require that
jobs be creative at all and some require
almost laughably few remember startup
New York zero taxes for a decade oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry don't
think about it I'm sure it will pass
that program is hiring requirements that
programs horan requirements were that
you create just one new job a year and
the state recently considered scaling
that back to one new job in the first
five years and sometimes these
incentives are given out even when they
may not be necessary take a look at
Fargo North Dakota you know what is not
wrong he's not wrong and I knew that
would do the job Fargo gave a tax break
to Fed Ex for moving a facility to their
city but why did they really need to
because just listen to what happened
when one city council member asked that
very question of a Fed Ex representative
mr. Wilson if you don't get this
exemption where you still move to Fargo
yes well we will okay yep ten minutes
later the council voted to give Fed Ex
that exemption why also if someone wants
to willingly move to Fargo you don't
offer them
incentives you simply offer them a full
psychological workup that starts with
the question who did you murder
what will still let you live here but we
do need to know and then then there are
programs narrowly setup to encourage a
particular industry to grow which can
sound great but may not lead to good
permanent jobs take film and TV
incentives at some point in the last
couple of decades nearly every states
decided that they wanted to be the next
Hollywood and now thirty-one states have
incentive programs for film or TV the
problem with that is if you are one of
them you have 30 other states competing
with you
hard and because film productions are
portable if you try and scale back your
incentives they'll just go wherever a
better deal is just listen to this movie
producer who has taken advantage of
multiple states incentives I would never
make a movie where I didn't get an
incentive and I don't ever intend to but
at the end of the day if there's an
incentive it's good for me look he's not
wrong I mean yes he looks like every
woman's worst ex-boyfriend but he's he's
not wrong it is not his job to worry
about whether his incentives are good
for States it is his job to I'm assuming
refer to sushi and sushi because he
definitely does that but but but it
should be someone someone's job to worry
about the effects of these programs and
on some occasions when states have done
that the news they got was not great
Bruce's Louisiana found that for every
dollar spent on his film program it
generated just 22 cents of tax revenue
which sounds bad but which is still
better than Maryland which made just 10
cents for every dollar spent which is
still better than Connecticut's program
which returned only 7 cents on the
dollar that's like putting a dollar into
a vending machine and getting a single
yellow starburst in return at some point
what you're getting out is not worth
what you're putting in and defenders of
economic incentives will say that's just
a fraction of the broader economic
benefit that they bring the problem is
there's not much evidence for that and I
know that accounting for the total
economic impact of anything is tricky
but we are gambling
millions of dollars on little more than
faith and even basic information can be
really hard to come by one study found
that three-quarters of major state
development programs don't even disclose
actual jobs created all workers trained
so we're basically throwing money down a
hole and hoping it brings us prosperity
which is the exact business model of a
wishing well and to see this at
perhaps its most pointless just look at
Kansas and Missouri they've offered
competing tax breaks to businesses for
years which has made things particularly
interesting in one metro area so I'm in
Kansas City Missouri
that's it behind me there is Kansas City
Kansas two states one metro area but
both states offer subsidies for job
creation create a job you get a tax
break so what a businesses do Missouri
business will move some employers over
to Kansas City Kansas and claim a tax
break moving back claim another tax
break it's true for instance Kansas City
Missouri lost corporate offices for all
these companies to Kansas City Kansas
which in turn lost offices for all these
companies to Kansas City Missouri and
that isn't creating jobs any more than
moving your couch from the bedroom to
the living room is creating
furniture and this war has come at a
real cost a local foundation has studied
two state level incentives programs and
estimates that since 2009 around 6600
jobs have moved from Missouri to Kansas
while around 5,500 jobs have moved from
Kansas to Missouri meaning there's been
a net gain of around 1,100 jobs on the
Kansas side of the line at a combined
cost to the two states of 331 million
dollars in lost tax revenue and think
about that for a second you could create
a program where the first 1,100 people
to move from to Kansas City from
Missouri would each get a Ferrari which
they could then drive around a giant
pile of thirty million dollars that the
state had set on fire and you'd actually
be fiscally responsible because you
would have saved the area twenty million
dollars
look it is pretty clear that economic
development needs to be done in a much
smarter way and I don't fully blame the
companies for this because if
governments are going to offer
ridiculous incentives they are going to
take them so governments need to hold
themselves and companies more
accountable and if companies aren't
producing what they promised we need a
system to claw our money back but to
find that out we're going to need much
more oversight over these programs and
what we're getting in return although I
will tell you one thing that I know for
sure we got in return the entourage
movie that got a five point eight
million dollar tax credit from
California and where else will they go
into film entourage I eat a hole so
California please know that you
indirectly had a hand in producing a
movie which may our mind you had this
for its very first line you know what
I've got to say this congratulations
Kentucky Ark Museum because somehow you
become the second worst taxpayer
subsidized boat in this story
[Applause]